Speaker 1: You might be saying, well, Jair
Bolsonaro must be right in there. Right? He must
be right in there with the insurrectionists and
the terrorists and the riders saying, I support
you and we're going to get this thing back.
But that is absolutely not the case. Bolsonaro,
and we're quoting The New York Times here,
has been holed up thousands of miles away
in the US state of Florida. Before
departing Brazil, the former president
urged his supporters to avoid violence. Jack
Nicklaus wrote this article for The Times. It was
updated just a few hours ago when his supporters
stormed Brazil's Congress and presidential offices
on Sunday to protest what they falsely claim was
a stolen election. Jair Bolsonaro is believed
to be thousands of miles away, facing various
investigations from his time in office. Bolsonaro
flew to Florida in late December with plans to
stay for at least a month. He's been in Orlando,
living in a rented house owned by a professional
mixed martial arts fighter a few miles from
Disney World. Bolsonaro has long questioned the
reliability of Brazil's election systems without
evidence, and he refused to concede unequivocally
when he lost in October to President Lula,
who took office on January one. Yet before
departing for Florida in the final days
of his presidency. Bolsonaro called on his
supporters to avoid violence and suggested
that they move on. We live in a democracy or
we don't, he said. No one wants an adventure.
Sunday evening, he criticized the protest, saying
on Twitter, Peaceful demonstrations are part of
democracy, but destructions and invasions of
public buildings like what occurred today were
not. He also repudiated President Lula's comments
that Bolsonaro bore some responsibility for the
riots, saying that those accusations were without
proof. There is some really, really wild video of
Bolsonaro in Florida. It just it's Kafkaesque. I
know it's for the first time in 2023, I'm pulling
the term out. It is sort of Kafkaesque. Here
is video of Bolsonaro in a Publix, just kind
of like looking around. It's surreal, almost. And
he seems to have security with him. Here he is.
Check it out. The register. And it kind of
looks like security is checking out for him,
which is interesting. I mean, that
seems like an interesting grocery
store experience. You're just like, I'd
like this. Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Right in
the cart. And then they they handle it. So. So
Bolsonaro can just look around. Just kind of
pacing aimlessly in a Publix waves to
the person filming. Yeah, you know.
Wow. Did you know these granola bars have four
grams of fiber per serving? This is stuff. We
don't have these in Brazil. Just bizarre. And
of course, the bigger questions here are about
his legal status in the country. I'm not going to
pretend to know the details of Bolsonaro's legal
status in the country. There's a few different
things that are possibilities, and I don't know
that we necessarily know. Commenters in Brazil are
saying Bolsonaro is in the U.S. on a diplomatic
visa now. Of course, the diplomatic visa is no
longer valid in the sense that he entered on
the diplomatic visa in December when he was still
president. He's not currently president. Now the
question starts to be, is he overstaying the visa
in a sense, because he was on the diplomatic visa,
he's no longer a diplomat. Does that make him an
overstay or. It's doubtful that that's classified
as an overstaying visa. Visas are usually valid
for a certain period of time, and once that time
elapses, it starts to become an overstay. If the
person hasn't left or renewed the visa or obtained
a new visa or immigrated in some different
way, we don't actually know how long Bolsonaro
is really planning to stay. Now there are people
talking about criminal charges and what happens if
Bolsonaro is criminally charged for something. And
it's conceivable that that would happen. In that
case, I would suggest a package deal extradite
him with Jorge Santos right back to Brazil. And
let's make sure that the legal legal system does
does what it's supposed to do. But regardless,
there's a lot of speculation as to the legal
status and the immigration status. I assure you
the State Department is very much aware
of Jair Bolsonaro being in Florida,
how he got here and how long he can stay. And
I am sure it will all ultimately shake out.
But the imagery and I don't even know whether
it KFC he was doing crispy strips of or the
bucket of chicken or what that is reporting
I would certainly like to learn more about
and whether he thought that the coleslaw had
mayo which apparently it doesn't apparently the
whole slot. KFC is completely vegan, much to the
surprise of many. No answers to those questions,
but just sort of hanging around while his
supporters are rioting in support of him
in in in Brazil. So bizarre and wild stuff. And
we are going to talk after the break about the
fingerprints that are all over this insurrection.
And you might not be surprised to hear that many
of those fingerprints are the fingerprints of
people who worked in and around the Donald Trump
White House. So that'll be after the break.
Wednesday, January 11th, two days from now,
is the first David Pakman show town hall of 2023.
Everyone is invited. Everyone can participate and
talk to me. We will be handling the the platform
we will use for you to talk to me is discord. You
can find our discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord. If you are a website member,
you will get priority access. Meaning I'll take
more calls from website members than nonmembers.
But everyone is welcome and we're going to take
calls from everybody. It will be. And I really
want to be clear because people said, what's the
date? What's the time? I'm telling you right now,
okay, write this down. Wednesday, January 11th,
at 6 p.m. Eastern time, 3 p.m. Pacific Time.
The event will stream and to call you go to
David Pakman dot com slash discord. We will
take a quick break and continue with so much of
the news from the weekend. Ladies and gentlemen,
the David Pakman show is a community supported
program. We do have a membership program. Join
Pacman dot com, which allows you to get lots of
great extra content and it allows us to fund our
operations. It is a very inexpensive thing and
a really great thing to do. You get daily access
to the bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show. Never
mind invitations to the exclusive members
only town halls and priority access to the
regular town halls like the
one scheduled for Wednesday,
January 11th at 6 p.m. Eastern. Sign up at join
Packman dot com and use the coupon code. Please
no more Trump. Please no more Trump. That's
the coupon code to get yourself a discount